- I love ending the show with a story
that could possibly bring
you a little extra happiness.
This is what I'm liking.
When the world shut down in 2020
a boy in the Northeast with nothing to do
grabbed his surfboard
and headed to the beach.
He made it his goal to surf
every day during lockdown.
Two years later he's still
going and hasn't missed a day.
Through sunshine, rain, sleet, and snow.
11 year old, 11 year old Carter has a goal
to surf 1000 days straight,
something that he is gonna hit
at the beginning of next year.
So let's get him in here right now.
Say hi to Carter and his mama, Dawn.
Hi.
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh, Carter. You're so cute.
You look like a little surfer
kid, that little dimple.
Oh my goodness.
So this is a huge commitment Carter!
So is it ever tough?
Are you ever like, this
was a poor decision?
- No, it's a lot of fun,
but it can sometimes get a little rough
when we get really high winds.
- And we're always out there
to make sure that he's okay
and that my husband watches him
and we make sure that
he's as safe as possible
and we can support his goals.
- That's amazing.
You must be an amazing surfer.
You look like a ninja
riding a wave just there.
Because you got to be all
covered up because it's snowing,
Carter, that is crazy!
So, and this isn't just about you, right?
Like you're raising money, right?
- Mmhm. Right now I just
started raising money
for the people in Ukraine to help them.
I've helped dogs get adopted
and raised money for Surf Aid
and helped my local food pantry.
- Oh my gosh, Carter!
What a great young man you're raising.
Oh my gosh, that's a beautiful thing.
Like to be thinking of
others at such a young age.
Thank you so much, Carter.
Thank you, Dawn, for
raising such a good kid.
- Thank you.
- I know you're going to make it.
Come back,
talk to us when you finally get
those thousand days, Carter.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pin
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, sir.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
- What do you say?
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, absolutely!